تحت الضجيج المستمر
للطائرات الإسرائيلية بدون طيار، يحفر الفلسطينيون في غزة مرة أخرى تحت
الأنقاض بأيديهم العارية،
وهذه ليست مهمة إنقاذ، بل
يجدون بقايا أحبائهم مسحوقين تحت
مبنى منهار،
إنها واحدة من أكثر الساعات الأربع والعشرين دموية في
غزة في حرب تقترب  في يومها الثمانين،
تقول وزارة الصحة في غزة التي تسيطر عليها حماس إن 250 شخصًا قتلوا في
الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية على مخيم أماجازي للاجئين
وبور ونوات القريبة منذ
بداية ليلة عيد الميلاد. ولا تستطيع سي إن إن
التحقق بشكل مستقل من الأرقام التي
نشرتها الوزارة في غزة
ردًا على أسئلة سي إن إن  قال جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
ردا على هجمات حماس الوحشية، إن جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
يعمل على تفكيك
القدرات العسكرية والإدارية لحماس
يشير جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي إلى هجوم حماس المفاجئ
ضد إسرائيل في 7 أكتوبر، حيث
قتل ما لا يقل عن 1200 شخص واختطف ما يقرب من
240 رهينة، ويظهر مقطع فيديو حصلت عليه
شبكة سي إن إن عائلات لا تزال تقوم بالحفر
حطام الأقارب المفقودين
يقول البعض أنهم ما زالوا مدفونين تحت
الألواح الخرسانية
للمباني المنهارة أطفال أطفال أطفال
أبرياء يقول
هذا الرجل إنه فقد 10 من أفراد
عائلته وعلى
المبنى المنهار يودع حبيبته
دينا العشرة  يقول الطفل البالغ من العمر عامًا إنه كان الشخص
المرح في فوضى الحطام،
لمحات من الحياة التي بحثت عن
الأمان من مكان إلى آخر في غزة، والأمر
متروك للجيران للعثور على
جثث العائلات المحاصرة
تحت المصابين الذين تم نقلهم إلى
مستشفى ألاسكا  خلال الليل كان المستشفى
يعاني بالفعل من تدفق
الإصابات والجثث من خطوط جوية أخرى
هنا في وضح النهار
اجتمع المجتمع معًا لطقوس الحداد على
الجثث أو ما بقي جاهزًا
للدفن كنت أنتظرك حتى تكبر
يقول إن العائلة انتقلت  من
ملجأ إلى آخر بحثًا عن الأمان،
يقول هذا الرجل
ابني الأكبر في كل زاوية، العائلات التي
تتصارع مع حجم
الخسارة [تصفيق]
الناجون من الضربات الجوية السابقة يأتون
لمساعدة
الناجين الجدد الذين فقدوا أحفاده
الشهر الماضي  هو السؤال الذي
يستمر سكان غزة في طرحه: أين هو
آمن، وهو السؤال الذي
يطرحه الكثير من الناس في غزة الآن،
أين هو آمن، سؤال آخر
يطرحه الناس كيف سيتمكنون من البقاء على قيد الحياة في ظل
الاعتقاد بأن جميع سكان غزة يعانون من أمراض حادة
انعدام الأمن الغذائي وهذه الحرب لا تظهر أي علامات
على التباطؤ في أي وقت قريب،
السؤال الآن كم عدد الأشخاص كم عدد
الأشخاص الذين سيموتون ليس بالضرورة
من الغارات الجوية أو ليس بالضرورة من
الرصاص ولكن المجاعة سوف ريبلي سي إن إن
تل أبيب